[Music]
on this sunday night a cop win or a cop
out
the world reacts to the global climate
deal we want to move quickly because
this is really important the big melt in
canada's north the land is changing like
dramatically the impermanence of
permafrost extreme restrictions returned
to europe the winter surge is coming the
cautionary tale for north america plus
the mental health handbook being handed
out on parliament hill
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us as the dust settles on the cop 26
climate summit how it went depends
entirely on who you ask a deal may have
been struck but an 11th hour edit to
soften the language around coal is
causing particular concern among
developing nations more vulnerable to
the effects of global warming
these are countries on the front line of
climate change and in terms of uh you
know china and india
i mean you know they will on this
particular issue have to explain
themselves to developing countries
but canada is championing the deal as a
groundbreaking success abigail beeman
has our top story tonight
glasgow has sounded the death knell
for coal power but did it many are
disappointed in the last minute language
revision to phase down coal rather than
phase it out and i am two
that includes canada's brand new
environment and climate change minister
although stephen gilbeau declares the
overall summit a success clearly
it's a win it's not everything many of
us were hoping it would be but there are
many things that we have now that the
conference has ended that we didn't just
a few weeks ago
while there is disagreement on the
question of declaring a cop win versus a
cop out virtually all of the rest of the
industrialized world has already done
more than canada has done and has
pledged to do more again but still
the collectivity of all the promises
made here in glasgow don't hold us to
1.5 degrees
most agree the attention paid to fossil
fuel and coal was groundbreaking and
some say the summit represented an
important shift it felt like the meeting
where climate change was busted out of
its you know environmental policy
pigeonhole and has become a much
more significant ordering principle for
the global economy canada's pledges
include phasing out coal by 2030 and
capping oil and gas emissions to get to
net zero by 2050 yabo isn't yet offering
up specifics saying more consultation is
needed first we want to move quickly
because this is really important if
we're still sending oil and gas on the
market we shouldn't kid ourselves that
we're betting on the failure of the
paris agreement and contributing to a
pretty awful world for the next
generation
catherine harrison says next year's cop
in egypt will see more pressure on
countries including canada to both boost
emissions targets canada stands at a 40
to 45 percent reduction by 2030 and put
more money on the table to help
developing countries go green
abigail beeman global news ottawa
there's another piece to the climate
change puzzle that canada must confront
warmer temperatures in the arctic are
thawing permafrost which accounts for 40
percent of this country's surface and
that big melt is releasing carbon that
has been locked away for centuries not
only that life is being disrupted in
these remote northern communities eric
sorensen explains
few countries in the world have
permafrost but canada has four million
square kilometers of it forty percent of
this country's land mass sits atop the
frozen layers that have held carbon for
eons but are now threatened by climate
change the permafrost is warming at a
rate of two to three times faster than
the global rate of increasing air
temperatures as the surface layer begins
to thaw
and intersects this ice rich layer for
scientists like scott dalamore
permafrost emissions while not man-made
must be dealt with the natural sources
of methane and co2 release have been
overlooked and the key area that's been
overlooked is in the permafrost areas
permafrost exists under the land and
below the sea floor centimeters beneath
the soil permafrost can be one meter or
several hundred meters thick as it thaws
plants decompose and carbon dioxide is
released the melt destabilizes the coast
landslides are quickly eroding the
shores with similar marine slides under
the ocean and methane long trapped in or
under the ice is also being released
methane is a more potent greenhouse gas
than carbon dioxide and is now bubbling
up all over the north
the impact has been dramatic in coastal
communities like taktayaktuk in the
northwest territories where thawing is
destabilizing roads and homes and the
ocean is accelerating the erosion
communities like fort simpson are
experiencing sinkholes the land is
changing like dramatically so
infrastructure could be the roads so
permafrost metals can
upset road road maintenance this will
also change
the dynamics of
how the wildlife are moving around
permafrost was supposed to be permanent
now scientists and the people who live
in the north have to rethink everything
from coastal and land management to the
health of people and wildlife in terms
of the community in terms of the north
the emphasis on adaptation to climate
change and adaptation to changing
conditions in permafrost uh is an
essential priority this time lapse from
researchers in alaska shows several
meters of coast washed away in little
more than a month it seems northern
countries have a new and urgent climate
burden to take account of what's
happening with permafrost canada has the
second largest endowment of permafrost
on the boat our responsibility as a
country isn't modest in this regard what
are the overlying sediments on top of
curbing man-made emissions canada will
need to look at how to track the natural
emissions across a vast and warming
arctic eric sorensen global news toronto
turning now to the pandemic new
lockdowns are being imposed in parts of
europe which is once again the epicenter
of kova 19. in austria the measures are
extreme targeting the unvaccinated and
that has led to protests but as jennifer
johnson explains experts warn the
situation in europe should serve as a
warning for north america
new cases of coba 19 are again sweeping
across europe a 50 jump in october and a
similar surge so far this month europe
is again the hotbed of a pandemic that
won't go away
i'm seeing the storm clouds gathering
over parts of the european continent
we've been here before and we remember
what happens when the wave starts starts
rolling in
1.4 million europeans have died from
copper 19
countries with the best medical systems
are no match for this virus even the
vaccinated are getting sick kobe 19 is
surging in countries with lower
vaccination rates in eastern europe but
also in countries with some of the
world's highest vaccination rates in
western europe vaccines do not replace
the need for other precautions but
experts say the world has become covet
19 weary and people aren't being careful
the patterns that we are seeing across
europe the patterns we're seeing across
the world are entirely predictable
because when you lift
public health and social measures you're
going to see the virus thrive another
lockdown begins monday in austria for
the country's 2 million unvaccinated
people
protests broke out in the netherlands
after a new partial lockdown was
announced to slow the spread of the
virus many europeans say they do not
want to go back to the early days of the
pandemic i was quite tired of working at
home sitting
on the attic behind my
laptop so
i'm not looking forward to doing new
lockdown i'm afraid medical experts say
what's happening in europe should set
off alarm bells in north america which
has followed previous european covet 19
surges doctors continue to urge everyone
to get vaccinated winter is coming and
the winter surge is coming unless we all
take collective action already cases and
hospitalizations are surging again in
dozens of u.s states and parts of canada
now experts fear the worst is yet to
come again
jennifer johnson global news washington
queen elizabeth has missed one of the
most significant events on her calendar
because of a sprained back
[Music]
she was unable to attend london's
remembrance sunday service britain's
ceremony to honor those who have lost
their lives to war members of the royal
family including her son prince charles
did appear he laid a wreath on her
behalf this was set to be the first
public appearance for the monarch since
being hospitalized last month the queen
issued a statement saying she was
disappointed she attaches great
importance to this day because she
served in the second world war as an
army driver and mechanic
[Music]
british counterterrorism police are
investigating a deadly car explosion at
a hospital officers were called to the
liverpool women's hospital shortly
before the blast one person was killed
and another injured so far three men
have been arrested under the terrorism
act
the biden administration in washington
has voiced its support for poland in its
border standoff with belarus it comes as
the polish government considers asking
nato to hold emergency talks over the
escalating situation
caught in the middle thousands of cold
hungry migrants who are growing more
desperate by the day critics say they're
being taken advantage of in what
essentially amounts to a propaganda war
redmond shannon reports
if you don't follow the orders force may
be used against you
much of the footage we are seeing from
this escalating migrant crisis either
comes from polish authorities or from
the belarusian government and state
media it is a propaganda war on the
eastern edge of the european union
the weapons as described by the eu
thousands of people from iraq yemen and
syria trying to get to europe but stuck
inside belarus
all the kids have got food now this
belarusian woman tells state media
poland and the eu say belarus engineered
the crisis by facilitating their passage
up to the border
belarusian leader alexander lukashenka
denies this his state media reported
that polish forces pushed 60 migrants
back into belarus on saturday after they
tried to enter poland something that
would be against international law but
was recently made legal in poland polish
leader matteo schmoyovsky wants nato to
intervene and the eu to fund a border
wall
the eu plans to slap belarus with more
sanctions monday lukashenka has
threatened to block a russian gas
pipeline to europe if that happens
his main backer and ally russian
president vladimir putin dismissed the
wisdom of such a move and denies russia
has any involvement in the standoff
temperatures are now dropping below zero
at least nine migrants have died some
due to hypothermia poland which has seen
an erosion of judicial and press
freedoms in recent years is not allowing
journalists or ngos near the scene we
shouldn't underestimate how important it
is to to have access to proper
confirmed data
through
the presence of median observers this
pregnant iraqi woman who made it into
poland said the ordeal was the most
tiring experience of her life but she
would do it all again for her children
redmond shannon global news london
the son of former dictator muammar
gaddafi is running for president of
libya safe al-islam qaddafi has
submitted his paperwork to run in the
election next month the exact date of
the vote is still up in the air over
fears of violence and disruption it's
also unclear whether he will even be
allowed to run gadhafi like his father
has been accused of numerous war crimes
and his election would likely be
resisted by several countries he's
largely stayed out of the public eye
since his father was captured and killed
in 2011. saif al-islam was also captured
but freed six years later
prime minister justin trudeau has raised
his concerns about the deteriorating
situation in ethiopia in a phone call
with his ethiopian counterpart abby
ahmed a readout from the prime
minister's office states trudeau
emphasized the need to respect human
rights and to ensure unhindered
humanitarian access and delivery of
humanitarian assistance to those
affected by the conflict the ethiopian
military has been battling rebel
factions from the northern region of
tigre for more than a year
all sides have been accused of human
rights abuses some of which may amount
to war crimes according to a recent u.n
investigation today the african union
warned talks to end the conflict won't
succeed without an immediate ceasefire
coming up politics is a blood sport
which is why some politicians are
starting to focus on their own mental
health
in just over a week the 44th parliament
will begin and it'll be the first to
include a minister of mental health and
addictions it's a significant step but
the government has released few details
about the new ministry and as david
aiken explains an all-party group of mps
is encouraging parliamentarians to make
sure they focus on the mental health of
canadians and their own
work on parliament hill it's a dream for
many being at the center of political
life in canada and there's lots of work
as many as 3 000 people have jobs as
political staffers for the nearly 450
mps and senators you meet a good quality
of people from throughout the country
matt conway spent a decade as a
political staffer but it was a decade
that he says was difficult for him
personally at times there were times
where all
that stress anxiety
was literally paralyzing to the point
where getting out of bed
in the morning was nearly impossible
work as a political staffer is a high
stakes job long hours not a lot of money
and almost no job security
my next mistake is the one is going to
get me fired and where am i going to be
then but though he was struggling conway
felt he could not ask for help going to
the chief of staff at the time wasn't an
option because
in my view that was putting my job in my
career on the line
now though as the new parliament gets
underway a group of parliamentarians is
urging colleagues to pay more attention
to their own mental health challenges
and to the mental health of their staff
it's not an easy job
it is not a nine to five job it is a
difficult difficult task awareness is
good
but it's not enough nova scotia senator
stan kutcher and toronto mp aris sachs
supervised the production of a mental
health handbook for parliamentarians
it's a resource guide to help mps
senators and their staffs we want to
make sure that in this unique
environment that we're working in that
our staff and ourselves have the
resources and tools we need to be able
to make good decisions
conway says this focus on mental health
is long overdue
when people are exhausted mentally
that is not the good conditions
the proper conditions to have great
policy decisions
which means improving mental health
among those working on parliament hill
could have a payoff for the entire
country
david aiken global news ottawa
still ahead the excruciating effects of
endometriosis and why it takes so long
to diagnose
endometriosis is an extremely painful
gynological disorder affecting more than
half a million women in canada but
experts believe that number is much
larger thousands of patients are being
misdiagnosed and even worse ignored as
jamie morocco reports doctors at one
toronto hospital are sounding the alarm
on what they call a substandard quality
of care
denise natalini says she suffered
excruciating period pains for more than
two decades it's to the point where i
was on the couch in the fetal position
sweating but doctor after doctor brushed
her symptoms off my quality of life
was terrible to the point where i no
longer could teach it turns out that now
50 year old had endometriosis a
gynecological condition where
endometrial tissue grows outside the
uterus causing pelvic pain soreness
during sex heavy menstrual bleeding
cramping and even infertility it's
estimated one in 10 women suffer from
endometriosis but in canada it takes
upwards of five years on average to get
a diagnosis toronto gynecologist dr
nacelio lemos who finally treated
natalini says he has a 500 patient wait
list alone
time between referral and surgery with
me today is at three years
because we don't have simply don't have
enough people lemos was recruited from
brazil in 2017. he says canada is years
behind in terms of testing and is still
using an invasive abdominal surgery
rather than the new standard an mri i
was shocked
to hear the term diagnostic laparoscopy
which i hadn't heard
for at least 15 years in brazil experts
say the fix is government funding health
canada says the onus is on provinces and
territories the funding is lacking the
understanding is lacking the advocacy is
lacking
and really the result is
is substandard care leaving more than an
estimated one million women like
natalini to advocate for themselves they
just didn't listen to me and
it's not normal to have this kind of
pain or risk suffering for years
without ever knowing why jamie morocco
global news toronto
up next a bc doctor's diagnosis of
climate change as a medical issue
there's a big focus on how climate
change is impacting the world around us
what may not be as evident is how it's
impacting our health a doctor in british
columbia is now giving some of his
patients a new diagnosis for what's
making them sick ted chernecki explains
this isn't the kootenais a family doctor
remembers as a boy i grew up in this
area and i don't remember
problems with heat or wildfire smoke
growing up at all
since i've been back for the past eight
years in the kootenays
more often than not during the summer
we're having a significant period of
wildfire smoke and then this past summer
with the heat tone
he and many of his colleagues in nelson
and elsewhere in the province have taken
to adding the words climate change when
filling out medical reports
no one can say for sure but logic
dictates that some of the patients
they're seeing shouldn't have symptoms
so severe if it wasn't for heat and
smoke and especially if it doesn't cool
off at night which it didn't this past
summer you know you get dehydrated that
makes it harder to manage your blood
sugars then your diabetes can go to
whack which makes it even harder and
even more likely to get dehydrated and
then you show up in emergency department
this map from health canada shows the
premature deaths per 100 000 for those
exposed to certain air pollutants worst
in the country is bc southern interior
and five of the top 15 regions in canada
are in bc with the okanagan similan
easily topping that list
an expert on air pollution believes our
health care system needs to be better
prepared for not if but when it's pretty
well understood that this is
something we should anticipate and it's
almost like we'll be lucky
if next summer we don't have something
like this he runs ubc's air pollution
exposure lab aimed at collecting the
science needed to know what air
pollutants via diesel fumes or smoke
particulates are doing to the human body
in some cases reducing pollution levels
can solve a lot of problems but that's
never going to happen with wildfires
people that can't afford air
conditioners etc that don't have them
they really should be supported by the
government because otherwise we're just
letting everyone down and we're not
talking about minor issues we're talking
about deaths nearly a thousand last
summer from heat alone so for the
beleaguered taxpayer subsidizing an air
purifier or an air conditioner for those
who can't afford it might be far cheaper
than even a short stay in hospital ted
chernake global news vancouver
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm robin gill tonight your
canada is this rainbow over marchmont
ontario we'd love to see your corner of
the country so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thank you for watching donna frieza will
be back at the anchor desk tomorrow and
i'll see you next weekend have a great
night
[Music]